from the air kentucky's governor
absorbed the damage below
one community of many where they will
have to start again
if they survived
the number no not to have made it
continues to rise victims of flash
floods which swamped these small
appalachian towns in minutes
these are some of the poorest
communities in america it's bad it
really is
we uh
been a fireman almost 27 years and this
is the worst i've ever seen it
people unaccounted for
probably 95 of the people in this area
here's lost everything houses cars
animals
it's
it's heartbreaking it really is scores
have been airlifted from homes cut off
and it's not just the floods
mudslides too hundreds of homes have
been destroyed
another unprecedented catastrophic
weather event
and again whole communities wiped out
and it's feared entire families too we
had to swim out
and it was cold it was over my head so
yeah
it was
scary
roads have been washed away power lines
down the mobile signal cut
all of it makes the rescue effort that
much harder
president biden has now declared this a
major disaster unlocking federal funding
and personnel
it is only seven months since he did the
same for the same state after tornadoes
ripped this place apart well in some
areas the water is receding as fast as
it arrived and that's clearly good news
for emergency crews like this one a
federal crew provided by the federal
government that have been working very
very hard throughout the day to try and
save more people and recover those
who've lost their lives
we've got at least six dead children
and um
that's hard
it's even harder for those families and
those communities and it's it's it's
gonna grow uh from there from everything
we've seen
we may be updating the count of how many
we lost for the next several weeks
for now the focus is on rescuing they
hope more will be found alive
but the number of dead may double
and more rain is expected mark stone sky
news
in kentucky